- We're here with one of my
favorite actors, Adam Scott.
And he's also a film buff who stars in
the new Apple TV+ show "Severance".
(audience applause)
So we're gonna test your
knowledge of best pictures
from Oscars winners of the past.
And if Adam can guess four correct,
we're throwing an Oscar's pizza party
for everyone in our audience.
That's right.
Everyone's gonna get a
gift card for not one,
not two, not three, not
four, not five, but six
deep dish pizzas from Chicago's very own
the wonderful Lou Malnati's,
which is like famous.
So famous.
- Delicious.
So...
- So pressure's on...
If I don't get them right, then we...
They don't get a pizza party.
Is that what's happening?
- I don't know, Adam, the
pizzas are in your hands.
Are you ready?
- Okay.
Yes, I am.
- Okay, first up it's
a movie from the 1970s.
See if you know what it is.
- Oh, Godfather.
- Yeah.
(ding)
Yeah, a hundred percent.
A hundred percent!
Ding, ding, ding, ding.
All right, we're going to the eighties
and the next poster piece is...
- "Chariots of Fire".
- Ding ding ding ding!
Yes, yes, yes!
Show me the nineties!
- "Forrest Gump".
- Yes!
(Drew cheering)
(audience applause)
- All right, I can taste the pizza.
I can smell the pizza.
It's getting close.
- I can smell it!
- I see cheese oozing.
Okay.
Moving on to this century.
- Oh, "Slumdog Millionaire".
- Yes!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Guess what!
- [Adam] Is that it?
- You did it!
That's four right.
Everybody gets the pizza party gift card
from Lou Malnati's to enjoy the Oscars.
And I say have some slices
and watch some "Severance"
which is streaming now on Apple TV+,
and new episodes are
dropping every Friday.
It's fantastic.
I can't wait for everybody to see it.
And Adam Scott, I'm so thrilled to finally
make your acquaintance
and my very best to you
and your whole family
including your Frankie.
- Yes, and to your Frankie as well.
Thank you.
I'm so thrilled to be on
your show and to meet you.
Thanks so much.
- [Drew] Oh, thank you, Adam Scott!